on a ouvert ce débat en disant que
islamo-gauchiste un terme d'extrême
droite mais ce que je sache certes il a
pu être adoubé par des personnes
d'extrême droite mais chacun a le droit
d'adouber ce qu'il le souhaite ça n'en
fait pas ça n'implique pas pour celui
qui a été adoubé qu'il soit complice il
n'a pas choisi qu'il a doublé et on voit
des personnalités de la gauche
républicaine
on voit au sein des défis et on a eu un
sondage récent qui montre que la majeure
partie de la gauche aujourd'hui se pose
la question cette question alors encore
une fois attention au terme de sa main
gauche et met en tout cas de pénétration
des idées qui sont des revendications 80
et c'est la définition qu'en donne et je
comprends que d'autres puissent
considérer que le terme est galvaudé
qu'il faut l'entendre selon d'autres
exceptions ma conviction profonde c'est
que un bernard-henri lévy une frédéric
vidal ont à peu près la même conception
qui est celle de dire attention nous
avons l'impression qu'une frange
minoritaire mais vous savez bien que les
révolutions toujours été faits par des
minorités agissantes une frange
minoritaire veut imposer un dogme veut
imposer une politique que radical alain
policard le disais ce n'est pas
l'intégralité des penseurs du des
colonialismes mais simplement ce sont
les plus agissants et que ceux là
peuvent induire des comportements
difficiles et attentatoire à la liberté
parfois de penser parfois d'un seigner
d'enseigner ou en tout cas disposer
disposer du dudu du canon des ressources
et des systèmes de pensée dont
l'université dispose est
traditionnellement voilà donc cette
question elle est essentielle et je
pense que c'est là le terme du débat
autour de la question de l'islamo
gauchisme
[Musique]